[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
keep your eyes open hey
what can i do oh you're back
oh thank you thank you if i look away
i don't know what this thing will do you
have to get me out of here
the door can only be opened by the
panopticon supervisor
that's langston if he's still around
langston yeah i know him i'll go ask him
how to get you out
please hurry my eyes
hey calm down just focus
what's your name focus
right my mind my name's phillip and
i think i can hold on for a bit it's
just my eyes my eyes hurt so much
just hang on phillip
yes
uh
there's someone named philip up in a
cell he's watching a refrigerator and
very rapidly losing it
phillip oh [ __ ] i forgot about fridge
duty
he's been in there for over a day i
totally forgot
you forgot about him there's a lot going
on
the hiss the benecoff tv considering the
number of things i'm juggling ma'am i
think it's listen it's fine
we just need to get him out of there he
said you'd be able to open the cell door
yeah i can unlock it on my terminal
there done door open but philip can't
just leave
the fridge is behaving erratically
ocular contact is the only thing that
seems to placate it
if we don't have someone in there
watching it 24 7 people will die
i'll figure something out i'm pretty
good with these things
being pretty good with altered items
isn't standard bureau procedure ma'am
he doesn't know us very well
what's the difference between objects of
power and think of them like
storms objects of power are like
tropical cyclones or
hurricanes for the uneducated they're
big rare
and scary of course directors can just
bind the oop and be
altered items are more like weird
thunderstorms some may rain frogs
some may rain corn and how does the hiss
back it's changing them
now they're all raining knives knife
rings nice metal
i'll see you later like always
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hello jesse i'm back
i'm coming in thank you
jesse the friend is doing something
phillip
it hurts me
this sounds like the board but i can't
understand it
so
wait there's no black pyramid here
the fridge seems fixed did fighting that
thing off change something
yes
you guys didn't bring like checkers or
anything did you
how'd it go where's phillip phillips
gone
something happened before i could get
him out
poor phillip you never did like fridge
duty
but if you're here then who's watching
the fridge
the fridge is fine now i took care of it
you don't just take care of altered
items what did you do
i touched it and wound up in the astral
plane
this thing was in there it was huge had
one big eye
wasn't friendly we've been getting
reports from the astronauts lately about
something fitting that description
the astral plane is usually connected to
our world through objects of power
not altered items
if this thing is linking itself to
altered items then it's clearly powerful
this may happen again do you think
that thing is what got philip
must have been the panopticon is a
dangerous place
the agents all know the risks but
since you're some sort of altered item
whisperer i've got a list of others for
you to corral
the hits are causing containment
breaches left right and center here
start with these i'll see if there are
any others missing while you're gone
my life just got a whole lot easier
[Music]
i'll see you later